the winner to organize FIFA World Cup is
Qatar
[Applause]
a total curveball the World Cup has put
Qatar on the map everybody knows Qatar
we welcome everyone we want everyone to
come and to enjoy and to experience our
culture
they'll do whatever it takes it is about
being able to exert soft influence over
a wide range of people the
criminalization of lgbti community is
non-negotiable it cannot happen
there is no doubt that FIFA was a
corrupt organization
we are not in a crisis we are only in
some difficulties yes it is the most
controversial World Cup in history
people are going to remember that this
first Middle Eastern World Cup was
something amazing
migrant workers really were treated like
animals they were placed in nothing more
than pens working in some of the most
extreme heat and humidity on the planet
this world cup is creating Legacy for
long-term sustainable progress that
lasts for decades after the last ball
has been kicked
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the World Cup is is the Pinnacle
[Music]
[Applause]
it is the best tournament in World
football
when it comes to Global spectacle little
beats football's World Cup
I was born and brought up in a town that
staged World a World Cup game back in
1966
I know what World Cups look like and
feel like and smell like
[Music]
police
language you speak cross classes across
across genders uh colors of skin
[Music]
every four years we see this in the
World Cup we see this everyone's glued
to their TV
[Music]
all right
everybody's talking about football about
this team or that team or this goal or
that tool
once the ball kicks off then the passion
of fans and everyone takes over
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the world cup is
you know is an incredibly powerful
vehicle for emotion positive and
negative
since 1930 the World Cup has been held
all over the world
the tournament is still reaching new
lands by going to the Middle East for
the first time there are 450 million
Arabs they are very excited to see the
world coming to that region to enjoy the
football the football unites the
football is not a tool for a division so
a tool for Unity
[Applause]
yeah football fans the hearts and minds
of football fans are the broadcasters
and the sponsors it's as simple as that
it is about being able to exert soft
influence over a wide range of people
and a broad range of people over an
extended period
becoming a World Cup host is an
attractive proposition and this year it
is in Qatar
the smallest country to ever host the
tournament
is a peninsula in the Gulf with a
population of Less Than 3 million
they had no background it had no history
of football it's not a footballing
nation they've had to go around the
world trying to find players to play in
their team as they joined FIFA around
their independence in the early 70s
the men's under 20 national team became
second at the under-20 World Cup in
Australia 1981 Qatar qualified for the
football tournament in the Olympics 1984
1992 2019
and one's AFC Asian cups
[Applause]
[Music]
population
three million people 90 percent of that
three million people aren't cataries
we're talking about 300 000 people by
the time you you know you take out the
basketball fans and you take out the
people who like going to the movies and
you take out people who want to go to a
shopping mall instead you know you're
left with
how many you know five ten fifteen
thousand hardcore fans
so why would a country with a relatively
Short history in the game go to the
trouble of hosting a World Cup
World Cup like the Olympic Games is
something that many countries have
wanted to do to present an image of
themselves to the world
after the second world war Tokyo hosting
the 1964 Olympics was a chance to show
that Tokyo had fully rejoined the
International Community
Germany 1972 with the Olympics died
again
and the Soviet Union hosting the 1980
Summer Olympics in Moscow
Qatar wanted that opportunity as well
there was there was much more at stake
for the category
until 1971 Qatar was a British
protectorate and so in essence Britain
made all of the big decisions for Qatar
and and essentially it was a thumb of
sand at the top of Saudi Arabia
so when Qatar became independent it
gained control of its oil and gas it
started to make its own decisions and it
took the decision to build its Nation
Qatar is an absolute monarchy and a
conservative Muslim Nation the energy
economy has made it one of the richest
countries in the world with exports of
liquefied natural gas funding ambitious
Investments at home and abroad
just since the late 1990s when the LNG
exports started as a country is rapidly
developing so Kata is a young country in
its National Vision it states the goal
to become an advanced country by 2030.
Qatar has to be admired for having a
strategic plan that was not just about a
World Cup Tournament but was about their
country it was about improving their
infrastructure
's commitment to the world cup over the
last 15 years has been Central to its
bid for Global influence
and in the Gulf relations between
neighbors can be tense having friends
and partners further afield is essential
the United States have a military basis
and very important one there Qatar did a
lot helping to get our
support people out of Afghanistan in
summer 2021 so they are trying to be
very diplomatic to live in peace with
many countries and from time to time
even to help to negotiate between
countries where there are tensions they
are trying to get independent as far as
possible
we see guitars and efforts to try to
really be a global player through
its expansion of its Airways there have
been efforts to have ownership of
English Premier League teams buying up
property investing in art
they want to be a household name just
like Dubai just like Paris just like New
York city that is their goal
thank you
a Qatari bid was long in the making but
it did seem outlandish at the time
nobody knew Qatar and this certainly has
changed Qatar so World Cup has put Qatar
on the map
I believe it's going to be a special
World Cup because of the amount of
attention that's been given to this
world cup from 2009 2010 when Qatar won
the bid
that bid was announced few took Qatar
seriously
I think it's absolutely the case that
you know when it came to how they won
the World Cup and how they've managed it
since they'll do whatever it takes
back then it seemed unlikely maybe even
impossible that the World Cup could come
here is the most controversial World Cup
in history I think in terms of the
complexity the sensitivity
the range of issues that not just FIFA's
face but obviously the category
organizers and others have faced
absolutely without doubt it is the most
controversial
possibly even sport mega event in
history
[Music]
this was the year England hoped to bring
the World Cup Tournament home for the
first time since 1966.
uh we're happy and we're ready for a
presentation they threw everything out
of bid for 2018
including football stars
and royalty
up against other European nations there
seemed even a sense of entitlement
well we've got a great bid we've just
got to convince the people in there that
we could do a great job thanks
well England would like to hold Another
World Cup because
I remember we invented the game
we took it around the world 2018 FIFA
World Cup
ladies and gentlemen will be organized
in Russia
they all got promised
by people that they would support them
and then they only got two votes
the voting was all in secret
22 members of the FIFA executive
committee never had to publicly declare
or explain their choice we didn't get
enough votes I think
it's uh that's obviously what we need
and what we we hoped that we would get
and what we believed that we would get I
just uh I'm sorry for the fans back home
in this hour but we did everything we
could
this was a total curveball
because For the First Time what we had
was the the tournament going to
countries that were diametrically
opposed to what had gone before
in this tough and fair fight
blatter was presiding over another vote
that day as FIFA president for the 2022
tournament destined to be held outside
Europe
so that left guitar up against the
United States South Korea Japan and
Australia I always remember being at a
meeting in Zurich in July 2009 and set
blatto walked in and he said I want the
World Cup to go to different lands and
you know there's a few of us who sat
there and thought Oh that's us because
we haven't had it it was an easy message
for us now give the Middle East this
chance it was a easy and Powerful
message that yeah I mean FIFA did need
to give the Middle East this opportunity
to host
the Americans were favorites to win it
as past hosts with a major commercial
Advantage the main thing the US has got
going for it is we can give a HomeTown
cheering squad for every team no matter
who makes the finals
you're trained on qatar's royalty
protocol and you never put the royal
family in a situation that will make
them look bad never ever ever I mean you
never do this so just the fact
the fact the audience was enough to know
that the name that was going to be
pulled out was Qatar
the winner
to organize
the 222 FIFA World Cup is Qatar
[Applause]
[Music]
I was at home in Sydney watching it live
I think about two or three o'clock in
the morning and my reaction was well yep
they did it
there was an anger I mean people
couldn't believe 100 what had happened
said blatter himself
knew it was a disaster he told me sir
to win
to win I mean that was the automatic
view that there's no way Qatar would
have won this unless they had been
corrupt
the decisions taken that night were a
turning point in the history of the game
these were new markets with big money
fast growth political political
influence
[Applause]
what we've now got Estates and that's
the crucial part States so the Russian
government and the Qatari government
realizing and understanding the
geopolitical power of the game but it
was the Qatar award that would attract
the most scrutiny
it was a choice that has some rationale
in contributing to the further Global
expansion of football and bringing the
World Cup for the first time to the
Middle East and to a Muslim majority
country
[Music]
a FIFA World Cup in the Middle East is a
wonderful aspiration
I'm sure everyone around the world a
fulsomely support
but this one has been awful the way that
it was done in 2010
the katari bed was ambitious and unique
their extreme summer heat and the
tournament always held in July would
need to be played in air-conditioned
stadiums
you couldn't hold this sort of
tournament in Qatar in the Summers just
too hot and even if you're going to
plant an air-conditioned Stadium the
fans getting from Stadium to Stadium
would have died in that heat
and they needed to build almost
everything
stadiums transport links accommodation
the cost would be huge
there's a lot of factors that go into
all of these but you know from looking
at a cost standpoint in a venue
standpoint
um it is quite surprising that Qatar was
selected how to respond to the heat
problem how to respond to the issues of
women how to respond to the issues of
laborers how to respond to the issues of
homophobia the media never asked these
questions
they were never taken seriously
ever
working in its favor was qatar's
convenient time difference to Europe the
most lucrative for broadcasters
but the footballing world still couldn't
believe it
oh they won it because they persuaded
the majority
on the FIFA committee to support them
and there are all sorts of question
marks over why why they supported them
those questions precipitated a flood of
accusations of corruption at all levels
of the game
whistleblowers from the Qatar on
Australia bids made claims of improper
payments in the bidding process
why do you think the FIFA executive
supported
money no other there's only one answer
and ask money if this if
you
the
the corrupt and people were prepared to
do whatever it takes to win that has to
be seen as being within a broader
context of how FIFA operated
after the failed U.S bid the FBI took
notice launching a wide-ranging
investigation into corruption across
FIFA especially into the sale of World
Cup TV rights
only 22 men make a major decision who is
becoming the next World Cup host the
less people make a major decision the
more tempting for corruption is a system
we are not in a crisis we are only in
some difficulties and these difficulties
will be solved will be solved inside our
family
a putrid organization at that time and
clearly you know Qatar took great
advantage of that
there is no
his note that FIFA at the period when
this was awarded
was a corrupt organization
16 members of the 2010 FIFA executive
committee have been accused arrested or
banned
zepplatter himself was forced to resign
in 2015.
legal cases into corruption are ongoing
in the U.S
no Qatari has ever been convicted of
wrongdoing in relation to the bid
they've had the finger pointed at them
for 12 years saying you won it because
you were corrupt and you know they've
had to fight that narrative for the best
part of 12 years we were accused by
bribing and buying the world cup two
investigations being carried out it's
been we proven that was untrue
I would like to know the truth I think
there are many people who would like to
to know the truth oh we're still waiting
for the Smoking Gun
um I've said the truth the proof is
still needed
um but I'm
I'm still confident
my sense always of Qatar is is that
Qatar didn't do anything that any that
others weren't already doing I think
Qatar probably played bigger and faster
but it was still playing the same game
as everybody else
eventually FIFA and catarr moved the
tournament to Winter a U-turn widely
expected by critics in a sense you know
Qatar they
applied and and advocated for the World
Cup on false premises
if you advertise to run a World Cup in
the summer
you win it and then you just go oh we
can't hold it then because it's too hot
sir
qatar's bed was a watershed moment
leading to a greater awareness of the
power game behind the sport
states with the tools and cash to burn
were trying to reshape their reputations
through the lens of football
it was given its own term Sports washing
[Music]
I characterize this as the putinization
of sport if you look at what what Putin
has done or how he has used sport over
the last 20 years
it's a bit like look at what I'm doing
with my left hand you know isn't that
Charming isn't that nice and in the
meantime punching with the right hand
Russia's 2018 World Cup was stayed
smoothly but it would eventually come at
a reputational cost for FIFA now aligned
with a country guilty of invading its
closest neighbor Ukraine
the industrial scale geopolitical stage
management of Russia 2018
was really something to behold the
Russian team was banned from competing
at Qatar 2022 but the question of sports
washing would cling to the story of this
World Cup but that has been subject to a
campaign a systematic campaign a
campaign of arrogancy who's not
accepting Qatar as a small country in
the Middle East to host such an event
for many FIFA's decision was the
original sin
I think that the award was unacceptable
you know the way it happened in back in
2010
to the basis of this award was not safe
and it resulted in unacceptable breach
of Human Rights
[Music]
unlike other hosts
Kata didn't just need to build stadiums
it needed to build all the stadiums
[Music]
what was clear in 2010 was that the
infrastructure in Qatar
wasn't adequate
to be able to host
this is a money no object World Cup
you keep in mind that we spent 10
billion pounds on the 2012 Olympics in
London this is a country that's spending
240 billion dollars on the World Cup and
it needed to build the infrastructure
that would support the tournament so
that means a road Network a metro line
an expansion of the airport it means
hotels to host fans and players and so
on I very often characterize this for
people as you know it's like real world
synths if you you know the kids console
game and you build a city
so it's a massive undertaking and one
that required a tremendous amount of
workers I'm with from other countries
they saw the World Cup as the Catalyst
to a revitalization and Resurgence and
reinvestment in their own
social infrastructure
which is perfectly fine
except for the fact that the world
should have known that that would
require several million migrants and
given the lack of labor laws that were
in place at the time football should
have realized that that was going to
come with an incredible amount of harm
football simply hadn't considered the
human impact of building this world cup
the treatment of Migrant workers had
been totally overlooked during the bid
process
there's something where amnesty or any
of these other organizations should have
stood up and said hey what this
country's
wanting to host a World Cup and should
have they should have started asking the
questions too to make people aware I
don't think people were aware of the
severity of it
it wasn't until 2013 that the
investigations uncovered the shocking
treatment of qatar's Migrant labor force
because we're being recruited into a
labor system that was already Rife with
abuse that was not fit for purpose
um for this kind of scaling up
the old kafala laws meant that migrant
workers really were treated like animals
they were placed in nothing more than
pens
they become indentured to their employer
they couldn't leave the country they
didn't have their passport there was
endemic wage theft more than 90 percent
of qatar's labor force is migrant
workers the highest in the world
foreigners have been employed under the
kafala system their presence in the
country is tied to an employer
they are working in some of the most
extreme heat and humidity on the planet
that puts your life in your your health
very severe risk
um they're often working very long hours
to a sort of punishing schedule and of
course they are not earning very much I
was visiting
labor camps where you would have schools
maybe you know more than 100 workers who
had gone unpaid for months
who often were struggling for food
so people in that situation where they
can't send money back to their families
it reaches a level of intense
desperation
and in one case you know I remember one
one man who you know had sort of
identified the date by which he wanted
to take his own life
figure of how many migrant workers have
died building the vast infrastructure is
disputed
Qatar claims three people have died
building stadiums but one estimate puts
the death toll at six and a half
thousand I tried to avoid
you know identifying a specific number
because we don't have good enough data
for that
and tell you one thing that three is a
really kind of outrageous response to
this issue there is this you know figure
of 6500 that is widely circulated and
often without the necessary context when
it was published back in in 20 2021 by
The Guardian
it was very clear that this is the total
number of South Asian Nationals who have
died in Qatar over a 10-year period it
made no distinction on whether these are
work related deaths or non-work related
deaths in fact it didn't make a
Distinction on whether these deaths were
of economically active people or
non-working people it includes people
under the age of 18 it includes people
over the age of 60.
construction is a dangerous industry and
accidents could be expected on a project
this size we may never know how many
deaths and injuries occurred on building
sites for World Cup infrastructure as
Qatari authorities haven't kept detailed
records when we are reporting that the
death that relates to the World Cup R3
64 500 is a untrue number which beer
reported and unfortunately
has has not been verified it wasn't
reported responsibly and yet we've been
responding to this number that has been
untrue when you look at the proportion
of of workers who return home to their
families you know having died their
death certificates don't properly
explain why they died they say things
like cardiac arrest
um or natural causes or you know heart
failure
it should be
you know considered essentially a matter
of
urgent priority to properly investigate
these deaths
[Music]
whether the number of people who have
died building this world cup is 350 or
even six and a half thousand each death
is devastating for their family back
home
at 33 years old and Carla Bell baser is
already a widow
a husband kasherim died in Qatar
he left his village in southern Nepal to
join the World Cup Workforce
[Music]
is
building the Metro transport system
connecting World Cup stadiums to
downtown Doha is
[Music]
the qataris put casharing's premature
death down to underlying causes but
dankala says her husband was a fit 32
year old and thinks working long hours
in intense heat was to blame is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign dankala now has two young
children to support alone
[Music]
across Nepal and South Asia there are
other families just like Dan Carlos
suffering because Qatar wanted to host
the World Cup and FIFA gave it to them
I think football should be played
everywhere
in the years after the decision it was
clear there was much FIFA had overlooked
lgbtq rights are suppressed very many
places
Qatar oppresses the rights of lesbian
gay bisexual and transgender people and
punishes same-sex relations with up to
seven years in prison
should the biggest arrangement in the
world which is a big big party it's a
big Global event should that be awarded
to countries where groups of people are
not legal
[Music]
the World Cup should never be held in
any country where the lgbti community
who are just simply one of our beautiful
tapestry of communities in football
where they're criminalized it just
shouldn't be possible I would say that
it should be a non-negotiable criteria
that people should at least be safe
human rights had been properly
considered by FIFA in 2010 it's hard to
see how Qatar could have prevailed it
took another six years for FIFA to
establish a human rights policy in 2016
under London president Johnny Infantino
we were asked to give advice to the
to the administration of
fermenting their human rights FIFA
um
amended its statutes in February 2016
saying in article 3 we will respect
human rights it's at that point with
years still to go that campaigners feel
FIFA should have acted we can still make
decisions on this tournament and Qatar
the criminalization of lgbti community
is non-negotiable it cannot happen it
needs to be rescinded you need to change
the law otherwise you're not staging
This World Cup
qatar's laws haven't changed so when it
says everyone is welcome not everyone
believes it we are welcoming everybody
we are not discriminating anyone and
we've been saying this
repeatingly that everybody is welcome we
would like to invite everyone to come
and to enjoy the football and to enjoy
the festivity and the celebration
you can say that they should feel safe
there and then but how could you really
feel safe I have to accept that I that
I'm married to a woman should risk to be
arrested in a world cup of my own sport
[Music]
I would like to thank the state of Qatar
the Federation the Olympic Committee
everyone for hosting us here now for
this Congress
and of course much much much much more
importantly
for the World Cup later
this year the World Cup which will
simply be the best World Cup ever and
the biggest show on Earth
with time running out before the
tournament Lisa klavanes made her move
to speak out on Qatar
for Maximum Impact she waited for the
leaders of world football to come
together
there is no room for employers who do
not secure the freedom and safety of
World Cup workers
no room for leaders that cannot host the
women's game
no room for hosts that cannot legally
guarantee the safety and respect of
lgbtq plus people coming to this theater
of Dreams
speech calling on FIFA to do more was
resented by some in the room who were
hoping they would finally be able to
move past the controversy
[Music]
I would like to inform yourselves
as well as the Norwegian Federation and
anybody who might share similar views on
the legacy of the World Cup who might
have doubts or questions about the
legacy of the World Cup that this world
cup is creating Legacy
not for 28 days
not for a few months
but for long-term sustainable progress
that lasts for decades after the last
ball has been kicked
I was very motivated to do it very
driven even though if it does not change
anything it was in itself very important
to have that as a part of the football
democracy and that last Congress before
the most controversial World Cup ever to
be hosted
there has been widespread acceptance
that change for the good has happened in
Qatar
a lot has changed in the country
and I think these changes need to be
recognized Qatar has now a minimum wage
Qatar has dismantled the kafala system
so one doesn't need approval anymore to
leave the country or to switch jobs
implemented
in good faith
really effectively and workers can
genuinely move jobs easily then that
could be quite transformative
despite making improvements to workers
rights and safety Qatar is finding
people perceptions of the country are
harder to change
I find a lot of people that speak about
this issue and work as welfare are not
experts in the industry I think they
need to really read and educate
themselves understand what's happened
over the past 10 or 12 years in terms of
Qatar
putting the effort into
changing legislation
progressing rights progressing working
standards introduction of of minimum
wage
the World Cup has been like a spotlight
on Qatar they've had to change and
change quickly they felt especially in
recent years the criticism has been
unfair
the Catherines simply weren't prepared
for the degree of scrutiny that they
received and they've to a certain extent
played catch up for quite a lot of that
12 years
we understand that any country would
host the World Cup will be subject to
some criticism but nothing has has
happened like what happened with
and there are lots of reforms which
being carried out by the country
yet no one is recognizing
[Music]
no amount of progress forgives the
original decision
should this tournament be happening
well it shouldn't be happening in Qatar
um there was never an argument for it to
be held in Qatar it was a bad decision
in the first place and I don't think as
the years have gone by
it the decision has improved at all
I'm amazed that they're hosting so much
has gone wrong for them
so much has gone wrong for FIFA you have
to wonder what has been the price
they've had to pay
change just did happen within FIFA and
qatarin but none of these changes
regardless of how great they are can
justify the wrongdoing that happens in
in the first years because it's you know
in principle it's it is unacceptable you
know it's it's football cannot impose
such risks
Qatar and FIFA are in this together both
forced to make changes to prevent
anything like this happening again
if I might have learned from the Qatar
experience for the future
that it should also contribute to make
the world a better place and not just
expand the game of football if you want
to abstain meaning you don't want the
criteria for awarding the World Cups
it's gone from
22 guys within the room that did not
have to say anything else that yes or no
to a country to a very thorough system
ever again would a World Cup house be
selected in such secrecy the vote for
the 2026 venue was opened up to FIFA's
entire membership of more than 200
countries
the member associations of Canada Mexico
and USA have been selected by the FIFA
Congress to host the 2026 FIFA World Cup
thank you
now where every award has to be based on
different risk assessments also human
rights and that that risk assessment in
in its turn has to be objected
objectively assessed again then through
Council of ufifa and then to an open
vote for all the members where you know
I I as a president what I vote will be
visible for all my members I think
international sport has been reflecting
on its recent decisions and starting to
steer in slightly different directions
foreign
has haunted this tournament for 12 years
and still does
FIFA is being asked to compensate the
families of Migrant workers who died
building Qatar 2022.
we're asking for the creation of a fund
a compensation fund
um and that should be at least as much
as we'll go in prize money to the
winning teams that
you know my view is still going to
significantly understand the scale of
losses but but I mean it's a starting
point so 440 million us is the amount of
the prize money pool and we're calling
on FIFA to give that same amount to the
families who've lost a lot of them
the issues raised by this tournament are
so profound that some players are even
making a political stand
Wasteland with faith bro the building
and Woodworkers International and the
International Trade union Confederation
seeking to embed reforms and an
establish a lasting Legacy in Qatar
Australia's decision to seek out raise
the question of whether it's the role of
players to protest
they're football players most of them
when they were 12 years old
uh you know they they weren't kicking a
ball around in your mouth she's thinking
you know what I'm going to be some kind
of geopolitical Ambassador for a gulf
Nation on some stage in the future they
they think in score a goal
for those people for those players who
alternatively do want to make a
statement
I would again endorse that I would
support it
so nowadays players athletes are very
outspoken quite many of them and that's
very helpful because that supports civil
society and others who want to work on
change
we are entering an era of athlete
activism so I'm glad that the times of
shut up and durable as a moderator on
ustv once tracing are over so I think
athletes have the right to express their
opinions
Sports should not never be politicized
and this is our stand we see the sport
as a tool for uniting people a tool to
bring the people together I told to
bring the world together
FIFA and Qatar both want to keep
directing the world's attention to the
sport itself the goals the saves the
shock wins and the dramatic upsets
that's why Qatar are spending 220
billion us to host it that's once the
Saudis want to host it
that's why you buy PSG that's why you
buy Newcastle United that's why you
start a live golf tournament that's why
is because when the ball is teed off or
the whistle goes and the goal is scored
most of the world forgets
that's the power of the sport and of
Sport washing
Qatar has built a nation it has branded
and positioned itself as a mega event
destination I wouldn't discount the
possibility sometime between 2030 2040
Qatar hosting the Olympic Games
the Qatar World Cup was Infamous before
a single match was played but will what
happens on the pitch have the power to
change the narrative
people are going to remember that you
know this first Middle Eastern World Cup
was something amazing
football cannot come in this situation
again without ruining football
has such a power to change things and it
can change it for the good when there's
greed involved it will never happen
small progress has been made can that be
built on that there is a need for a
collective effort not to let our eyes
off the ball
never forget that there are people who
paid for our emotion and our joy and our
celebration with their lives in the end
it's about football it's about the
matches should it be separated from the
mother suspect where it was awarded and
sort of very strange things that have
gone on in Qatar over the years well I
think they'll be forgotten sadly but
they will be forgotten
Qatar have fought off controversy and
defied Convention to deliver this world
cup
they played the power game and won but
at what cost
Qatar has now ascended to this
prominent position in the world but also
a position of trustworthiness and
legitimacy which can you put a financial
value on this I don't know if you can I
don't think you can but that is why they
set out to host the World Cup in the
first place foreign
[Music]